we had Jacob AI here I fell in love with
him he's he's so sweet so sweet little
Aussie boy I was like oh my gosh he's so
sweet but one of the things that I first
of all how did y'all Bond I'll ask that
question first just because y'all didn't
know each other before this right so
you're playing these intimate you know R
right well sometimes you get on the set
and it's okay to meet on day one and
roll right into it but you know playing
Elvis and Priscilla we knew I knew that
we had to have that connection and had
to have that trust in each other so when
I found out he got the role I was so
excited cuz I loved his work but I
didn't know how he was going to be um so
I basically emailed him and forced him
to hang out with me be friends you will
be my friend I was like do you want to
go horseback riding cuz that was
something Elvis and Priscilla loved to
do and he was so game and I love oh yeah
oh I've been there that's on Sensei
that's I've done that Hollywood yes I've
been there that's so awesome but it's
kind of hard to have a conversation
though yeah I know it was so awkward
he's like behind me riding a horse I'm
like uh so what are you close with your
family and this like group horseback
riding trip uh no but he was so great
and he was so like connected with the
the hor like he's such a Outback all
like yeah no I love him and one of the
things I loved about him that we found
out is he's an amazing photographer and
he took my favorite picture he took as a
view I don't know if you've read your
card yet but I was like I hope you get a
copy of it I have to show this picture I
want to see this oh this is not what
I've seen no no this is beautiful I've
never seen that one it was another one
that we showed but anyway we could show
it oh I've never seen that one
either they us they gave us more oh my
god there he's such a great photographer
I know there was there's this one and
you look like a first lady like it's
this one that they showed whenever he
was on it's so beautiful and I just was
like I hope you get this picture he
should send this to you this should be
your Christmas present I just love that
he did that because we Shot the movie in
30 days so I sort of have amnesia when I
think back on it so it's so fun to see
those photos and it it was such a wild
Journey we all went on a month yeah had
to finish I know only a month I just got
anxiety for you and it's already done I
was like wow
[Music]
[Applause]
okay thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home